the manticore is a beef similar to some
that we've seen before not too
dissimilar from the Sphinx in the
Chimera in Egyptian and Greek mythology
originating from Persian mythology the
manticore was classically shown as
having the head of a human of the body
of a lion and the tail of a scorpion it
was also sometimes depicted as having
poisonous spines or porcupine like
quills and it would shoot from its tail
in mobilizing its victims from afar the
manticore was a lethal predator and
developed a reputation as a maneater
because it was known to eat its victims
whole its rows of razor-sharp teeth
meant that not even bones were left
behind it's been featured in the host of
beastie reach throughout the years but
it's still commonly mistaken for the
medieval creature known as demented
tiger which as its name would suggest
had the body of a tiger the head of an
old man was the tusks of a ball and long
spiral-shaped horns in the Persian
region the manticore was originally
known as the muddier core essentially
meaning maneater it wasn't until the
influence of the ancient Greeks that the
pronunciation began to change
tamati hora which would eventually
become Manticore now there are
definitely some similarities between the
mantacorn the Sphinx which features in
Greek and Egyptian mythology but when we
take a closer look we can definitely see
that they are not the same creature the
two creatures can be seen as somewhat
hybrid monsters but the manticore was a
predator davara and its prey hold and
display in very instinctual behavior
these Fink's on the other hand takes a
very intellectual approach toward its
killings it's able to speak very
eloquently and it gives its victims a
chance to save themselves it only killed
those who are unable to answer its
riddles correctly I'd compared the
behavior of the manticore most of the
Chimera in Greek mythology with them
both being extremely feared because of
their aggressive and deadly nature the
appearance of the manticore and how it's
changed is quite interested in its body
has been shown as anything from a lion
to a tiger to even a bear and in its
earliest depictions it was never shown
with wings but over the years it seemed
to have developed these web-like wings
not too dissimilar to that of a bat the
ability to fly does indeed make the
creature more terrifying and the same
can be said for the transformation of
its head from a human to a lion the idea
of the body of a lion were they
of a man is quite an odd concept but
it's not one that strikes fear into
those that lay the eyes upon the
creature removing the human element and
replacing it with the head of a lion an
animal that we consider to be one of the
deadliest predators on land and then
given it the ability to fly does make
the manticore seem more dangerous in the
manticore we have an extremely dangerous
predator one that is fast and strong but
also merciless in his hunt for flesh but
I'd like to know what you guys think
have you ever heard of the manticore
before which combination of creatures do
you find most terrifying and deadly let
me know in the comments below as always
I've been your host Anthology in fiction
explained